we've learned something new today or did
we today we're gonna smoke a little bit
of marijuana and we're going to see how
long it takes us to get on high by doing
a few specific activities we should
probably learn a little walk in there
exercise water pick up snacks coffee are
you ready for this
yeah I think first step is obviously you
got to get high so let's go do it
yes we're back and we are very Hey OOP
recording to say that we are now high so
we're gonna walk around for a little bit
see if it calms us down because right
now we're here and we got to get down
here I'm gonna start a timer on my phone
to see how long it takes us to get on
all right fall in
oh we are walking and walking and
talking is beautiful
[Music]
this isn't working for me
let's just head back I felt like it's
been a little while and I'm still not
quite so okay so we're gonna try the
second thing jumping jacks alright so we
were to walk glasses it was definitely
up the ante and try to do jumping jacks
and push ups to one TARDIS
if it it helped right now I'm tired of
how that did the opposite of what we
wanted yeah I just got so much more I'm
like twice as I say water water water
water water
[Music]
and then we get butterfingers here no
the water portion of this exam didn't
really do much for me we are officially
in the smacking portion yes we are right
now I have some Lucky Charms fled the
water brought me down just a little bit
and a good way up like I'm at a nice
place goldfish
fruit snacks and dry cereal Lucky Charms
I have so far eaten all of the
marshmallows I found out that holy no
I'm pretty hungry I could eat you know
[Music]
how are you feeling the post copy very
honestly I think I'm I think by the time
I weighed we get my father I'm a soldier
I'm feeling a little bit more so very
finally finally so we've learned
something new today
or did we I kind of we're back I'm gonna
adventure a large part of it is just
being out and moving around and drinking
water drinking coffee it's been about an
hour too so that I mean time just time
yeah okay so we started off and we set
up in the wall yes so the walk I feel
like did not help at all it was more so
just like seeing the beautiful things
around like it almost made me more high
because it was so euphoric seeing how
beautiful how they is doing push-ups
it got my blood flowing like all that
weed that was in my beloved sitting
dormant
yes as cue said I definitely continue to
feel more yeah I feel like we
experienced a lot we found out a lot
from this I think what worked for me was
the coffee I think the coffee ended it
for me and the cereal coffee for sure
and time give yourself time or freakin
lay your head down on a pillow and take
a nap I'm not gonna lie I do still feel
high so I so all this was a lot of fun
but we would like to remind you to
please make sure you consume marijuana
in a safe and responsible or in the
virus
[Music]
you